merci Jérôme durant de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de
Saône-et-Loire de Saône-et-Loire
vice-président de la commission des Lois
du Sénat on va parler de l'audition
Gérald Darmanin dans quelques instants
ce sera cet après-midi mais d'abord on
va parler de ce qui s'est passé hier
puisque Emmanuel Macron on l'a vu a reçu
plus de 200 m qui ont été touchés par
les émeutes retours à l'ordre durable
républicain que nous voulons tous et
auquel nous allons nous appeler qu'on
nous appeler y compris avec des moyens
exceptionnels c'est ce qu'a dit le chef
de l'État est-ce que le message est le
bon il fallait évidemment recevoir les
maires
je ne sais pas si le message est le bon
ce que je peux dire ce dont je peux
témoigner c'est que sur le terrain
puisque dans mon propre département des
communes ont été durement touchées il y
a une véritable attente d'aide de l'État
par les maires pour réparer ce qui a été
abîmé des des mairies brûlées des salles
polyvalentes
détériorées du matériel public endommagé
évidemment on a besoin de l'État
la question maintenant c'est
au-delà des annonces quel calendrier et
on voit qu'au strict plan législatif ça
va être compliqué de mettre 109
puisqu'en loi exceptionnelle de
programmation de loi d'urgence de
programmation de moyens donc quand c'est
la question vous posez parce
qu'effectivement il a annoncé la loi il
a pas de donner de détails il a pas de
données de calendrier est-ce que pour
vous ça peut être examiné avant l'été
c'est très serré j'ai le sentiment que
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale y
a El Braun Pivet se demande comment elle
fait entrer aux choses pieds ce nouveau
texte dans une session extraordinaire
qui est déjà bien encombrée qui s'arrête
le 21 juillet il va falloir aller très
vite parce que l'urgence sur le terrain
elle est là est-ce que pour vous cette
loi elle doit contenir un fond d'urgence
pour les communes qui ont été touchées
par ces émeutes est-ce que c'est à
l'état de payer oui il faut il faut que
l'État apporte son concours à ce qui
s'est passé et d'une certaine manière
l'État est aussi un peu responsable de
ce qui s'est passé il y a une solidarine
nationale qui doit s'exprimer les mers
ont vu des circonstances extérieures
intervenir chez eux et l'embrasement il
doit beaucoup à des causes nationales
donc il est normal que l'État soit là au
rendez-vous ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end notamment à L'Haÿ-les-Roses
avec le domicile du maire à Vincent Jean
Brun qui a été attaqué vous auriez
souhaité que le Président de la
République annonce de nouvelles mesures
de protection contre les élus on ne sait
se dénumérer des mesures de protection
alors on durcit on a beaucoup de de
dispositions d'amendements dans
l'émotion qui correspondent à des faits
réels je pense que le problème de fond
c'est le climat politique et social du
pays
c'est ça qui c'est sur ça qu'il faut
travailler le problème c'est aussi la
réponse judiciaire c'est la réponse
judiciaire bon il y a une loi
qui manquent c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
forcément compliqué la loi c'est déjà
appliqué la loi et puis c'est changer le
climat parce que là on est dans la
réparation on est dans le maintien de
l'ordre mais en amont il faut pacifier
le débat politique et le climat social
est-ce que les socialistes demandent un
débat parlementaire sur ses émeutes et
sur la sortie de crise quel est
l'utilité ça permet quand même de mettre
au jour les raisons profondes de ce qui
s'est passé alors on sait que c'est
multifactoriels on a beaucoup incriminé
les familles monoparentales les mers
célibataires le déficit de la politique
de la ville ça explique une partie des
raisons de l'embrasement mais dans
certaines zones comme celle dont je suis
le représentant il y a sans doute il y a
une espèce de contamination mimétisme on
n'est pas forcément dans des quartiers
politiques de la ville très très
durement touchés par les difficultés pas
partout en tout cas il y a aussi un
sujet entre la police et la population
il va falloir qu'on revienne sur cette
question justement on va en parler des
rapports entre la police et le
population et d'abord cette information
qu'on a appris que un homme de 27 ans
est mort à Marseille dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche une enquête a été
ouverte et selon les premiers éléments
de l'enquête il est probable que le
décès était causé par un choc violent au
niveau du thorax causé par le tir d'un
projectile type flash-ball quand
dites-vous on était presque
heureux de voir que malgré la violence
des incidents il y avait pas eu de
blesser de mort voilà donc il faudrait
que l'enquête fasse toute la lumière sur
ce qui s'est passé on reviendra
j'imagine dans d'autres conversations
sur la question de la contre du contrôle
de la police et des enquêtes et je pense
que c'est on est au cœur du sujet et de
la question du maintien de l'ordre mais
d'abord vous auditionner cet après-midi
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur la gestion de ses
émeutes est-ce que l'exécutif a bien
géré sur le plan du maintien de l'ordre
écoutez je crois qu'ils ont dépêché
président de la République la première
ministre et ministre de l'Intérieur
beaucoup de moyens
on a parlé de 45000
forces employées donc globalement si la
situation s'apaise on aura quand même
circonscrit dans le temps les
difficultés même si les dégâts ont été
immenses puisqu'il y a eu en quelques
jours autant de dégâts qu'en 2005 sur
trois semaines
la question je pense elle est en amont
le maintien de l'ordre je pense qu'on a
fait le travail et moi même vu dans mon
département les forces qui étaient
dépêchées à Mâcon donc je crois que là
on a plutôt été au rendez-vous mais
malheureusement c'est un peu tard et
c'est tout ce qui précède qui pose
problème qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
coup cet après-midi Gérald Darmanin
qu'est-ce que vous allez lui dire
écoutez nous on a eu un débat très très
nourri pendant la locmin la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère d'intérieur il y a quelques
mois sur les refus d'obtempérer on était
revenu mon groupe et j'en étais
l'orateur sur cette question de la loi
2017 l'article
435-1 du code de sécurité intérieure la
fameuse faculté d'utiliser son arme pour
les forces de l'ordre encadreux de
tempérer et je pense qu'il faudra quand
même s'intéresser au fait générateur et
puis plus généralement
je pense qu'il faut l'évaluer c'est en
plus c'est une loi qui a été portée par
les socialistes donc je suis assez à
l'aise pour dire c'est notre travail de
voter la loi c'est notre travail de
l'évaluer donc il faut pas dire c'est un
permis de tuer cette formule elle est
elle est odieuse
et puis le correspond à la réalité en
revanche la réalité c'est qu'il faut
qu'on fasse ce travail d'évaluation il y
a des chercheurs qui documentent un
nombre plus important de tir et de tirs
mortel depuis la mise en oeuvre de cette
qu'en est-il est-ce que c'est la loi
est-ce que c'est son application est-ce
que c'est la formation des polices les
policiers c'est notre travail d'évaluer
tout ça et en fonction la revoir
éventuellement bien sûr
il y a une fracture aujourd'hui de la
police et la population selon vous oui
et ce qui est intéressant c'est
peut-être de remonter aux sources du
Beauvau de la sécurité vous souvenez de
cette opération qui avait duré plusieurs
mois et le fait générateur c'était
l'affaire Michel zeclerc qui était entre
guillemets une affaire de violence
policière ou en tout cas
un comportement inapproprié des forces
de l'ordre et puis on est parti sur le
Bovet de la sécurité l'affaire éclair
c'était des violences illégitimes entre
guillemets et puis c'était un soupçon de
racisme une fois que le bobo de la
sécurité est passé on a plus jamais
entendu parler de ça et on a dit
vous avez parlé donc pour vous c'était
pas suffisant c'était pas suffisant on
sait que le beau de la sécurité ça a été
une vaste opération de de RH la
ressources humaines pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur et de communication à
l'extérieur et au fond on se rend compte
qu'on n'a pas traité les questions qui
mérit
[Musique]
et Fabien vecker qui s'installe bonjour
Fabien merci d'être là Fabien en diffus
je le disais votre documentaire vendredi
à 16h30 maintien de l'ordre le malaise
intérieur est dans ce documentaire vous
avez suivi Jérôme durant sur le terrain
alors on s'est penché sur ce sujet du
maintien Nord un peu pour les mêmes
raisons que vous Jérôme Durin avec une
interrogation comment expliquer le bilan
humain de la France en la matière un
bilan très lourd puisqu'on compte à ce
stade trois morts dans des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre de PI 2014 de très
nombreux manifestants mutilés pendant la
crise des gilets jaunes et plus
récemment deux personnes dans le coma
après les affrontements à Sainte Soline
et c'est justement après les événements
de sainte Soline que la commission des
Lois du Sénat laquelle vous appartenez
Jérôme Durin a auditionné le ministre de
l'Intérieur et lors de cette audition
Gérald Darmanin vous a en quelque sorte
lancé un défi je vous propose de le
réécouter c'était le 5 avril dernier
pour voir ce qui toute la journée ils
ont comme violence en face de
alors j'ai besoin vous avez pris Gérald
Darmanin homo et vous êtes donc parti en
observation le 1er mai dernier avec une
unité alors non pas de la Bravet mais de
la brave la brigade de répression de
l'action violente mon motorisé celle-ci
on vous a suivi ce jour-là et donc c'est
le l'objet de l'extrait qu'on va
regarder qu'on va regarder maintenant
l'unité de Jérôme Durin se déplace en
parallèle de la manifestation prête à
charger en cas de débordement à l'avant
du cortège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grosse attaque et donc visiblement ils
sont prêts
[Applaudissements]
que ça bloque pas que ça fasse de points
de fixation et donc ils interviennent à
échéance régulière parfois contourne le
dispositif le défilé pour que tout ça
continue et de progresser
de
Black Bloc ils appellent ça nébuleuse
qui qui sont pris à des agences
bancaires à des commerces effectivement
aux forces de
vous avez pris Gérald Darmanin homo et
vous êtes allés suivre cette unité quel
bilan vous tirez de cette expérience
d'abord la confrontation avec la réalité
le maintien de l'ordre c'est sans doute
dans toutes les missions de la police la
mission la plus complexe et c'est le
sale boulot et il faut reconnaître que
ces unités là elles sont confrontées à
la violence la plus crue donc
forcément le maintien de l'ordre il y a
l'usage de la force il y a des violences
et la question pour nous pousse citoyens
et pour moi comme parlementaire c'est
jusque quand cette violence elle est
légitime à quel moment elle devient
illégitime et comment on exerce le
maintien de l'ordre avec
des moyens un niveau de formation une
doctrine d'emploi qui est quand même
protectrice et liberté publique et ce
que disait tout à l'heure pas bien
équerre sur le nombre de blessés les
morts parfois et pas adm en démocratie
même si c'est une des missions extrêmes
de la police mais est-ce que ça a changé
votre vision parce que vous dites dans
le reportage de Fabien vous aviez vos
convictions vous avez vos principes
politiques et vous avez voulu les
confronter à la réalité du terrain
est-ce que quand vous avez été confronté
à cette réalité ça a changé votre vision
du travail de la police et du maintien
de l'homme évidemment j'ai vu la
complexité de la tâche la confusion la
brutalité
la réalité opérationnelle le bruit les
assauts de des Black Blocs les
projectiles en tout genre les mortiers
forcément ça change j'ai vu aussi que
l'image était partout on se souvient du
débat sur l'article 24 à l'époque de la
sécurité globale l'image est un enjeu
extrêmement pratique sur la diffusion
malveillante d'images de policiers qui
étaient censuré et d'ailleurs l'affaire
Naël le drame de Nanterre il vient des
images et d'une vidéo donc je me suis
rendu compte à quel point il fallait
documenter ce qui se passe et du coup ça
interpelle sur la formation j'y reviens
sur le contrôle externe comment on
vérifie ce qui se passe et comment on
tient une mission qui est très dure qui
est très complexe pour éviter que ça
dégénère parce que forcément toutes les
tous les ingrédients dans le maintien de
l'ordre sont réunis pour que ça se passe
mal donc il faut qu'à la fin que ça se
passe bien c'est la difficulté vous
dites avoir été marqué par le niveau de
violence que subissent les forces de
l'ordre bien sûr bien sûr alors on dira
et naïf le parlementaire mais
franchement ce jour là je crois que ça
tapait fort
Fabien du coup on va regarder la suite
de votre partage les violences en
manifestations sont donc la faute de
manifester
ont changé en tout cas vous évoquez le
rôle grandissant de l'image et en marge
des cortèges bien ordonnés organisés par
les syndicats avec des rituels et
savoir-faire sont apparus des mouvements
plus éruptifs aussi plus violents le
phénomène Black Bloc les gilets jaunes
ou plus récemment les manifs dites
sauvages contre la réforme des retraites
donc à partir de là la question c'est de
savoir si le maintien de l'or n'a fait
que réagir finalement que s'adapter ou
s'il porte quand même une part de
responsabilité de responsabilité dans
une spirale de violence on a posé la
question à Fabien Jobard il est
sociologue spécialiste du maintien de
l'ordre et de la police et Fabien Jobard
nous invite à faire un peu d'histoire
les années 90 2000 ce qui se multiplie
en France sont ce qu'on appelle les
violons urbaines
[Musique]
il y a eu une contamination du maintien
d'ordre c'est-à-dire de la gestion des
manifestations par les violences
urbaines la réponse aux violences
urbaines telle qu'elle a été conçue
telle qu'elle a été équipée dotée durant
les années 90 et surtout durant les
années 2000 une décennie pendant
laquelle le sociologue a observé ce
qu'il appelle la brutalisation du
maintien de l'ordre c'est l'impact à qui
est recherché en violant urbaine c'est
l'impact en maintien de l'ordre on est
sur une disposition tout à fait
différente manifestation ce qui est en
recherche c'est le contrôle des foules
on va essayer de faire en sorte que la
foule
aille d'un point un autre sans commettre
de dégâts et quand on a vu notamment
avec la loi travail 2016 les mouvements
sociaux tels qu'on les connaît
habituellement revenir sur le devant de
la scène le maintien de l'ordre il avait
été pendant 20 ans contaminé car les
faire les violences urbaines les
équipements n'étaient pas les mêmes
les doctrines n'étaient plus vraiment
les mêmes
et puis la culture aussi des policiers
avait changé et c'est ça qui fait
la la dureté la prêter la violence de la
réponse au
mouvement sociaux
voilà donc Fabien Jobard soulève
notamment la question de l'équipement
qui fait finalement la vraie spécificité
du maintien de l'ordre français si on
compare aux pratiques des autres polices
européennes et deux armes en particulier
le lanceur de balle de défense le fameux
LBD dont on a beaucoup entendu parler
pendant les gilets jaunes et les
grenades explosives qu'elles dégagent du
gaz ou qu'elle soit assourdissante et
dont l'explosion
occasionne parfois des blessures graves
et pour ce film nous avons recueilli le
témoignage d'une femme elle s'appelle
Doris elle a 50 ans elle vit à Rouen
elle est syndiquée à la CGT elle
travaille dans le milieu scolaire elle
n'a vraiment rien d'un membre du Black
Bloc elle a fait toutes les manifs
contre la réforme des retraites jusqu'à
celle du 23 mars et ce jour-là elle a
essuie un tir de Grenade lancé par les
forces de l'ordre qui lui a arraché le
pouce donc elle est évidemment suivi
médicalement en arrêt de travail
prolongé on imagine et en fait le cas de
Doris soulève quand même une question
comment est-il possible qu'une
manifestante entre guillemets lambda qui
participe à une manifestation déclarée
puisse être victime d'une blessure aussi
grave alors Jérôme Durin faut-il engager
une réflexion sur l'armement des
policiers dans le cadre du maintien de
l'ordre oui il faut la poursuivre il y a
déjà eu une actualisation du schéma
national du maintien de l'orge c'était
il y a deux ans il faut poursuivre cette
réflexion à l'évidence et les dernières
manifestations le dernier cycle mais les
stations sur la retraite prouve que on
n'est pas sorti malgré cette
actualisation du schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre malgré des rapports
il y en a eu un au Sénat sur la façon
dont le maintien de l'or doit être
exercée on n'a pas encore fait notre mue
vers quelque chose qui va vers la
désescalade ce que d'autres pays
s'affairent il faut pas être un livre
sur la question
la
les manifestations la violence dans la
rue c'est la continuation de la
politique par d'autres moyens d'une
certaine manière donc quand il y a des
manifestations à la fin c'est compliqué
mais normalement on doit pouvoir tenir
ça après il y a un phénomène un peu
spécifique qui est les Black Blocs qui
eux sont extrêmement
violent et qui viennent uniquement pour
la violence c'est pas simplement des
manifestations qui tombent mal c'est des
gens qui viennent pour casser sans
prendre aux personnes donc là sans doute
que il faut aussi qu'on adapte notre
dispositif à cette forme de violence
particulière la question du
renseignement paraît importante aussi
c'est-à-dire que comment en amont on
essaye d'éviter que des gens arrivent
avec ces intentions et parfois ces
outils pour s'en prendre bien aux
personnes et après avoir les moyens de
faire des arrestations préventives du
coup arrestation préventive faut qu'on
fasse quand même très attention à nos
libertés publiques parce que on est
quand même dans une période où ça va
loin on a eu il y a pas longtemps
l'activation des téléphones à distance
la reconnaissance faciale proposée par
un texte au Sénat
je pense qu'il faut déjà qu'on est qu'on
est qu'on applique ce qu'on a dans les
cartons en termes de moyens et puis
qu'on pacifie le climat j'y reviens mais
dans un une société bien organisée
les gens parlent un peu moins fort et
s'expriment un peu moins fort donc si le
climat social un petit peu plus calme et
ça c'est vraiment du politique on se
pose les questions du maintien de
l'ordre dans les termes différents
dans votre documentaire ça pointe aussi
les conséquences des baisses défectives
dans la police tout à fait et
effectifs qui ont fait ont eu pour
conséquence de d'envoyer en première
ligne des policiers dont le maintien de
l'ordre n'est pas le métier alors
rappelons-nous la politique de non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
pendant le quinquennat de Nicolas
Sarkozy sa politique elle a eu aussi une
incidence sur les policiers et notamment
sur ce qui sont dédiés normalement au
maintien de l'ordre c'est à dire les
compagnies républicaines de sécurité les
CRS les compagnies de gendarmes mobiles
qui sont donc des forces aguerries
formées au maintien de l'ordre qui ont
vu leurs effectifs baisser et quand au
moment des gilets jaunes les autorités
ont dû faire face à des besoins humains
énormes pour maintenir l'ordre à plein
d'endroits différents du territoire en
même temps et bien c'est forces
spécialisées les forces mobiles
n'étaient plus assez nombreuses donc on
a eu recours à des supplétifs c'est à
dire des fonctionnaires qui sont entre
guillemets prêter main-fortes et qui
n'étaient pas formés au maintien de
l'ordre par exemple des policiers venus
des bacs des brigades antiques
criminalité dont le métier d'abord de
faire de l'interpellation donc d'aller
au contact et pour les syndicalistes
policiers c'est notamment ce qui
explique certains dérapages et par
exemple le recours inconsidéré au LBD
pendant les manifs de gilets jaunes qui
ont causé de très nombreuses mutilations
c'est aussi pour vous l'une des clés
l'une des explications de ce qui se
passe elle baisse d'effectif dans la
police bien sûr je reprendrai une
formule d'un de vos collègues qui a fait
une immersion dans un commissariat du
Nord et qui
donne cette formule d'un policier des
commissariat qui dit à propos de la
droite républicaine la droite qui nous
adore quand ils sont dans l'opposition
parce que on est la sécurité et puis dès
qu'on est qui sont dans la majorité ils
souviennent qu'on ait des fonctionnaires
et donc il supprime des postes bon ben
voilà Sarkozy les années Sarkozy c'est
ça et après quand on supprime plus de
10000 postes on part de très loin et il
y a un sujet de recrutement et les
conditions de recrutement sont très
difficiles le niveau de recrutement est
d'ailleurs parfois assez bas ça a été
dit dans des rapports sénatoriaux il y a
la question de la formation qui est
insuffisante là aussi des rapports
notamment du Sénat lundi et quand on
recrute mal quand on forme mal que la
doctrine d'emploi est floue ben voilà ça
donne ça des manifestations qui sont mal
maîtrisées des gens qui sont blessés ou
tuer et parfois des gens qui sont
utilisés pour autre chose que ce qu'ils
savent la police c'est un terme un peu
générique mais derrière il y a des
spécialités il y a la police judiciaire
qui est assez malmené qu'elle maintient
l'ordre il y a ceux qui sont sur la voie
publique c'est les métiers différents
donc si on est utilisé pour faire autre
chose que ce pourquoi on a été formé
forcément ça donne des erreurs de part
et d'autre parce que vous dites Nicolas
Sarkozy il a baissé les effectifs mais
la baisse de la durée de formation ça
vient pas de Nicolas Sarkozy est-ce que
la diminuer le temps de formation des
policiers ça aussi été une erreur
d'ailleurs c'est il y a eu une
modification de la doctrine du président
Macron
dans le dernier quinquennat puisque
après avoir baissé on est remonté
à 18 mois et c'est heureusement une une
dispositif qui est une disposition qui
sera
utile pour la suite mais encore
recrutement attention et dans la locmie
dont vous parlez la programmation de
ministère de l'Intérieur il y a une
augmentation pour le coup des effectifs
est-ce que du coup ça va apaiser la
situation ça peut diminuer les
confrontations ou pas
sur la loop me j'ai presque envie de
faire une adresse à Gérald Darmanin on
en veut pour notre argent nous on a voté
la loopnie c'est pas naturel pour nous
et et on en veut pour notre argent
maintenant on a mis 15 milliards en plus
donc il faut que ça produise des effets
et ça tarde et il faut reconnaître alors
ça commence à se déployer mais les
dernières les derniers événements
Nanterre les problèmes systémiques qui
ne sont pas résolus il faut que la locmi
les résolvent sinon on sera passé à côté
de du contrat qui a été passé dans le
reportage de Fabien vous dites on sent
que les forces de l'ordre payent pour
d'autres qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
par là
mais c'est le bout de la chaîne les
forces de l'ordre quand le climat
politique est aussi tendu et je donnais
à Fabien Ecker une anecdote à la fin de
la manifestation place de la Nation
quand je suis avec la colonne de la
brave et qu'on passe sous les sifflets
des manifestants
on sent quelque chose qui ne concerne
pas que la police en gros c'est la même
scène que quelques années auparavant
après les les attentats à l'époque les
policiers étaient
encensés étaient applaudi elle était
encouragé et là on passe sous les
sifflets les hués les noms d'oiseaux
c'est donc quelque chose qui est abîmé
et ça les policiers ne le doivent pas
qu'à leur propre action doivent un
climat politique et quand on s'en prend
aux policiers un jour de manifestation
on s'en prend au pouvoir on s'en prend
Emmanuel Macron donc moi je le redis
c'est la passification du débat public
et puis c'est résoudre des questions qui
se posent durement dans la société et
qui n'ont toujours pas trouvé de réponse
le reportage très instructif de Fabien
bravo pour ce reportage et t'avoir sur
notre antenne vendredi à 16h30 et déjà
sur notre plateforme public sénat.fr
merci beaucoup merci Fabien d'être venu
merci Jérôme du Rhin d'être venu
évidemment vous êtes au cœur de ce
reportage qui est donc à voir sur notre
antenne dans 20 minutes dans le top des
territoires on va revenir sur la
rencontre en Emmanuel Macron et les
maires victimes des meutres on sera avec
l'un d'entre eux Christophe Houillon qui
nous dira ce qu'il en a pensé d'abord on
accueille notre invité c'est Jean-Pierre
Raffarin nous rejoint